the Pantages Theatre in Hollywood and
the century theater in New York it's the
28th annual awards of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences ladies
and gentlemen the Academy Award
orchestra with Andre Previn conducting
you might like to know how Academy Award
winners chose in early February ballots
are sent out to 15,000 members of the
various motion picture crafts and guilds
each person marks his ballot and posts
it to the accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse the results are tallied and
the five top entrants received one of
these the Academy certificate the five
names in each category are placed on the
final ballot this ballot is mailed to
the 1,700 members of the Academy to mark
this in secret and send it to dry
slaughterhouse the final tally is made
the results are known to only two people
a Pricewaterhouse man here and one in
New York the winners will receive one of
these the Oscar their names are in a
stack of sealed envelopes on the stage
first these envelopes will be opened
shortly so you can tell your neighbors
in the morning you are one of the first
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences mr. George
Seaton
good evening ladies and gentlemen during
the past year the motion picture screen
has become wider and wider it has also
become truly international it has viewed
the world from every part of the world
if this presentation has a theme that is
it consider the five nominated pictures
tonight each one was shot in most part
in the actual locale last year 38
American companies were shooting
pictures abroad when the Academy was
born 28 years ago the number was 2 and
now happily enough the reverse is true
foreign companies are shooting in the
United States a Japanese company has
recently been on location here in
California a French company is planning
to journey to New York and an Italian
company to Chicago all this implies more
than setting up a camera it implies
perception and understanding of those
people and those locales so we may fully
hope that in the days to come when we
speak of widescreen what we will really
mean is bread of vision and now our
master ceremonies a young comedian I
have always enjoyed in the last twenty
four hectic hours I have learned to
respect him mr. Jerry Lewis
Thank You mr. Seaton the way I'm dressed
tonight I should be selling cools I
would like to say that ladies and
gentlemen you were here tonight to our
live television performance of our pride
tomorrow
we're gathered here tonight ladies and
gentlemen for the annual Academy Awards
formerly known as Disneyland as you
probably know last year Bob Hope is the
master ceremonies and it did a very very
wonderful job and they tried terribly
hard to get him to do it again this year
but unfortunately he couldn't be located
he was at home give you an idea of how
Bob travels and he travels quite a bit
the stickers on his trunk a mark
anywhere anywhere it's a form of a gag
oh heavens but Bob is really a wonderful
guy and he's always going some way to do
something for someone specifically
entertaining the troops and you may not
know this but bob has a very very fine
grown son and he had to enlist just to
see his father that's also in the form
of dad the straight lines you'll kind of
get and these gags will seem a little
questionable but help me won't you
before I go any further a DS and
gentlemen I should like very much to
thank mr. Jack and Trotter and the Sands
Hotel in Las Vegas where Dean and I are
currently appearing for allowing us to
appear here tonight and I must publicly
thank my good partner Dean Martin
because last night in Las Vegas at the
roulette wheel he arranged it so that we
will be in Las Vegas for five more years
matter of fact we did two shows in Las
Vegas ladies and gentle ass night then
we had a fly in and we just about made
rehearsal here at the Academy and I have
to thank the freeways the freeways here
in Los Angeles
those are the ones to thank because we
never figured we make it on time for the
freeways is such a fantastic thing today
what were the overpasses and the
underpasses and the circles and the
turns etc I don't care where you live in
the city of Los Angeles all you have to
do is get in your car get on the freeway
and in 15 minutes you're a loss
matter of fact I live in the Pacific
Palisades I live in the Pacific
Palisades ladies and gentlemen the other
night I got in my car got onto the
freeway and in a matter of minutes I was
downtown Los Angeles the only trouble
was I was going to the corner for a
newspaper
Smaug must use the freeway because it
gets to my house in no time
the last gag I'll ever buy from a
trumpet player but I do want to say
you have a note here ladies and
gentlemen from the Motion Picture
Academy reminding me to thank Walt
Disney for loaning us these Oscars
tonight
these are the jokes let's face it what I
do want to say I might add that mr.
Disney very seriously has earned every
Oscar that he has been presented with he
has earned it ladies and gentlemen he's
a great showman the reason all this
pictures make a fortune is simple it's
obvious he pays his stars very little
what can a gopher make do
all I want is the good meals bring since
they were on location a couple of months
ago for the African lion
they were shooting a scene this
afternoon and at noon the director
yelled lunch and before he knew what he
was
oh yeah we go on ladies and gentlemen I
do have several important announcements
to make and the first is from the
management of the Pantages Theatre we
would like you to know that because of
the length of the Academy Awards tonight
the second feature will not be shown
also is an announcement for all the
people that are here for the awards
tonight the police department has asked
me to tell you the double parking will
only be permitted for losers oh I knew
that one and another thing ladies and
gentlemen the people in the audience
please don't throw your popcorn boxes in
the aisles please don't do that this is
your Academy keep it clean oh yes and
another thing I do want to make mention
the fact that this year the foreign film
is the most important aspect in the
motion picture industry for some reason
as a matter of fact the foreign pictures
are getting better and better as Danny
Kaye told me on his recent visit to this
country I agree with Danny I love
foreign pictures particularly the
Italian pictures I like them with Gina
Lollobrigida who I like that kind of
picture except the English titles throw
me a little bit when you're looking at
gina lollobrigida who can read he gots a
gag about a girl
but if you know there are five nominated
songs ladies and gentlemen five songs
that are being they that what they're
trying to get the Oscar these five songs
and they will be played tonight and we'd
appreciate it ladies and gentlemen here
tonight when the songs are played please
no dancing thank you
we would like now to take you to New
York City to meet a very lovely and
gracious young lady
a former Academy Award winner if you
please miss Claudette Colbert ladies and
gentlemen
good evening mr. Lewis mr. Lewis my
tails must be coming over very nicely
who is that what they are Jerry you look
very distinguished and this evening we
have a very distinguished gentleman here
in New York to help me present these
award a four-time Academy Award winner
as writer and director mr. Joseph L
mankiewicz
Jerry Jerry I must compliment you all of
us back here are amazed at the dignified
manner in which thus far you have
handled the proceeding may mr.
mankiewicz the character with which I
have been identified that of the raucous
buffoon is merely a study portrayal in
natural life I am quite the antithesis
for your edification when it comes to
dignity deportment and composure I'll
make a slob out of Ronald Coleman Jerry
I suggest that you take the show on the
road yes ma'am
keep laughing like that honey anyhow I
would like to say if mr. Bill Miller of
Price Waterhouse is available we would
like to get started to present the
documentary Awards of the evening a
young lady who is herself a nominee for
her performance in interrupted melody
ladies and gentlemen the very lovely
Miss Eleanor Parker if you please
there are two awards in this category
tonight the first is for a documentary
Short subject and the winner is men
against the arctic wolves Disney
we'll except for this today Jewell and
on behalf of alt studio staff all the
wonderful walt disney photographers
thank you very much
and now for the feature-length
documentary the winner is in New York
Helen Keller in her story
Nancy Hamilton
Oh
I hope that the winning of this award
will mean as much to Helen Keller's
friends all over the world as it means
to us who had the privilege of making
this picture thank you thank you very
much and if you will please at the stage
door stop Eleanor Parker she's got a hot
award on her hands cabe went away and it
should have been done in New York I'm
terribly sorry
oh I'm not well at all to present the
award the sound recording ladies and
gentlemen a nominee for performance and
rebel without a cause mr. Sal Mineo
or sound recording Yamba lovely the
winner is
Oklahoma Fred hi
thank you in behalf of all the members
of the sound Department who worked so
hard for this especially Joe Kane Murray
step back Glenn Rominger thank you